well if there's resource sources that
are coming out and saying this there are
credible sources uh the west middle
police uh take on this sort of this sort
of action very very seriously and unless
there's a particular competent source
that they're aware of they wouldn't have
done this so obviously there's a clear
source who said this and
therefore i think people are looking to
copycat uh what's happened before and
will perhaps attempt something like this
the thing is the police have to be out
and about and so they represent a fairly
soft target to a self-starting terrorist
of some kind oh very much so and i think
this is why important that they wear all
the protective
gear that they're entitled to where they
should be wearing that i think more
importantly rather than traveling on
their own they should be at least in
pairs i believe that's what's happening
in birmingham at the moment
but it is a very very uh vulnerable
target for uh people to have a look at
but we need to be aware of what's
happening and how the community can
ensure that we support this telling them
not to use public transport to go home i
mean that's quite a difficult thing for
a lot of people well it is because most
people don't gen get into a car or uh
drive a bicycle but they keep the
uniform on in most instances they just
put a coat over the top of it so i
suppose they will have to take their
uniforms off uh when they're traveling
back home at least and to perhaps uh
trying to deter some of those things
happening to them how successful in
birmingham have the police been in
getting an integrated force
not as successful as they should be but
they've done well they've done better
than most uh uh west midlands uh police
force has done much better than most of
the authorities we need to go a long way
uh still to do a lot more and i think
that should be uh or something that we
need to look at but it's difficult
climbing at the moment for police forces
to do that because they're cutting their
numbers uh and as the government's
already said they're cutting another 30
000 across the country
after the next election so that would
make it even more difficult today we've
been in in parliament addressing the
terrorism bill but we can do all of
those things once we have the proper
resources for police and the
intelligence and the services that we've
got i mean do you think the reductions
in the budget we've also seen today the
metropolitan police selling new scotland
yard that famous building
are both
reducing the effectiveness of the police
and also putting them in greater danger
i think certainly both of those uh
certainly the effectiveness uh i've seen
that in my constituency uh some crimes
arising and we need to stop that and
that used to happen with the numbers
that we've had and to reduce that even
further will certainly have a
detrimental effect to policing in all of
our communities because of course the
impact of some of these guidelines don't
wear your uniform when you're not on
duty don't travel on public transport
is going to mean
that the separation between the police
and the public is going to be all the
greater that we're not going to have
that presence well that's that's what we
had previously with the army uh when
when that happened uh and only recently
the
advice was to start go back into uniform
but i think what we've got to do is we
need to get this awareness across to the
whole of the community and we need to
get community support for the police as
well and like you said we're getting
better in creating an integrated police
forces are much better for the whole of
the community
if
this this continues uh will the police
have to really i mean you said for
example uh
always wear your your stab fest and the
rest of it but if this continues are the
police gonna have to
really look again at the way they work
for example patrolling on the streets
i think yes i think that will ultimately
if it continues but i think what we've
got to do is the address the whole issue
of radicalization
and i think unfortunately over the last
four and a half years or so we've taken
eye off the ball as as a government in
the country and we need to get back to
that particularly with what's going on
with isil
across in
iraq and syria and we need to look at
this threat we need to look at how would
you radicalize some of those young
people and that's a real serious issue
for us to deal with kelly madwood thank
you very much for joining us